the State Department has instructed the
New York medical examiner not to
disclose the cause of death for the
recent Russian ambassador to the United
Nations passing the background is that
there have been a number of these
suspicious Russian deaths and there's
been lack of clarity on the causes of
death and the circumstances a lot of
sketchiness one of those deaths was
Vitaly Churkin the Russian ambassador to
the UN and I previously told you that he
died suddenly at work in his office and
the office of the chief medical examiner
said the details of the death were being
withheld to comply with international
law cause of death still unclear people
have continued looking into it because
it's so odd we now have a statement from
the medical examiner's office that it's
only adding fuel to the fire of
suspicion New York medical examiner
spokeswoman julie vulture said quote the
new york city law department has
instructed the office of chief medical
examiner to not publicly disclose the
cause and manner of death of ambassador
Vitaly Churkin in a letter to the city's
legal office the United States's UN
mission said the Russian government had
already complained about statements made
by city officials regarding Jerkins
medical history Russian officials are
arguing that the information was private
and that disclosing the details could
cause embarrassment to the ambassador's
family or hurt his reputation that makes
it even more sketchy particularly
because the New York medical examiner
previously said that both the cause and
manner of death of the Russian
ambassador to the UN needs to be studied
further that's not in and of itself
suspicious but it does suggest that the
death wasn't a simple open-and-shut
saying we need to be looking into this
in more detail we are going to continue
covering it but just a quick update
about if and when we're going to figure
out what the official cause of death is
there